this ties his career high in points to
the most important game of his
young nba life mccollum for three cj
mccollum from downtown
and the game is tied about the shot by
cj get some ice hold on john moran
little shoulder
cj mccollum so they try to set a screen
and get him off of him
mccullum kicks it out anthony for three
rebound nurkic
banks at home and a foul and portland
has regained the lead
and then step back knocks down the jump
shot how about this big guy
nurkish he's been outstanding blazers
now clinging to a one-point lead
mccollum a three-pointer bang cj
mccollum from downtown
that can take over games also in cj
mccullough
john morant had it deflected and turns
it over
drives pulls up puts it in
cj mccollum clutch here in the fourth
quarter and portland has a six-point
lead
and guard me no disagreement here mr
mccollum
flat out getting it done says allow me
to have this dance
knocks down the beautiful jump shot mama
there goes that man and here comes john
moran
still four-point game under a minute to
play
morant the hesitation shot blocked by
trent
left good job by gary trent jr getting
back into the
pitcher
lillard one-on-one with allen drives
kicks it out anthony anthony for three
bang
carmelo anthony makes it a six-point
game
20 seconds remaining big three-pointers
from anthony once again
if i put the ball in your hands as a
license to make the play
not the score damon lillitt unselfish
superstar
puts